so welcome to my talk on dotnet core
data security hope is not a strategy my
name's Steven haunts I'm an offer for
Pluralsight it's been with him for about
six years now and done twenty one
courses with them mmm
I'm a freelance trainer and also Mycroft
MVP which means you get a nice little
blue badge it's all about the blue badge
okay so the reason why I do this talk
and I've done various versions of it
this one's tailored more towards my core
is because as developers it's kind of
our responsibility I believe to try and
protect the information assets of our
company by making sure that we encrypts
their information and do key management
security a lot of companies tend to have
this kind of attitude or psyche ones
I've work with back in the UK you guys
you know if we just cross our fingers
we'll hope that no one no tries to steal
any of our data from our databases and
you know then end up in have IBM pound
which is what nobody wants so generally
we tend to get companies using hope as a
strategy or a security strategy and you
know I've worked for many companies
across many different market verticals
financial services healthcare things
like that and you know there has been
kind of a blase approach in some
instances and you know this is kind of
like a typical manual that you might get
when you're working with a project
management team okay that one didn't get
a laugh we want to a bad start okay so
what this talk isn't about so this talk
isn't about maths it's not about you
know how things are IES work under the
covers as interesting as it is as
developers you don't really need to know
that unless you tick you want to peer
under the covers and it's also not about
breaking codes cryptanalysis or any of
that sort of cool stuff what it is about
is about people like you and me who are
on the front lines in our company is
building software solutions you know
pretty much every developer me always
has the same story that there's never
enough time to deliver what they need to
do and the Compu on so everything now so
this talk is aimed at you know people
that are working on software systems
they want to you know know about how to
do cryptography and other things in in
dotnet so this is kind of like a allele
intros kind of what you can do
so typically art this stuff originated
from the dotnet framework or the you
know the more traditional dotnet
framework typically would run server
side during client code where Microsoft
started the dotnet called journey
o saintly rat 1.0 version 1.1 the
cryptography support in that version
of.net core was severely lacking you
know you had a few hashing functions and
that was pretty much about it so dotnet
core really became a serious contender
from dotnet core 2.0 and don't net
standard 2.0 which is great you know we
started to get some feature parity with
the.net framework and the good thing is
now you know no in the realm of dotnet
core 3 and above we actually get a few
more additions that been waiting for him
net for a long time which we gonna talk
about tonight so what this is a very
Microsoft focus talking that we're
looking at some of the API is there
available to us in essence the
principles of what we discuss in a kind
of universal so where you working
microsoft.net PHP Java Python node
doesn't really matter the principles are
kind of the same just we're looking at a
Microsoft API so what we're going to
cover and cover quickly there's anyone
here who's in my workshop no that's good
except I see can get the same
information again so we're gonna look at
random numbers we're gonna look at
hashing and H max hash message
authentication codes we take a little
look at secure password storage
symmetric encryption with ies and the
new AES GCM mode has just been
introduced into doc notes we look a
little bit about asymmetric encryption
in RSA although I'm sure everyone's in
the keynote this morning and he's not
worried about RSA and we'll look at
digital signatures which also suffer the
same quantum related problems but we'll
save that problem for another day and
then we'll look at some examples about
how typically some of these things might
be combined together so I think having
Zhai end-to-end encryption work or TLS
protocols work so we'll look at how you
can some you know mix some of these
things together so it's cryptography so
it's generally about protecting
information typically we think of
encryption when we doing that which
involves encryption keys
the result of an encrypted message is
often called the ciphertext and the art
of trying to break cryptography is crypt
analysis but really there's a lot more
to cryptography than just encryption so
there's kind of four core pillar areas
that we talked about with cryptography
so we have confidentiality
you know encryption making something
confidential we have integrity so making
sure that if I send a piece of data to
someone that it hasn't been tampered
with or corrupted in transit where for
authentication which is similar to
integrity but it's about you know do you
have permission to check the integrity
of this file or piece of data and then
we have non-repudiation which is about
being able to prove you as the
originator of a message so cryptography
is used everywhere and you literally
cannot get out of bed without
cryptography being involved in your life
somehow even though Jevon is quite
transparent so online shopping if you go
onto Amazon or any other websites just
using your browser you know you have
your browser and servers you know
negotiating keys between each other and
communicating securely taking money out
of an ATM you know there's a
cryptographic handshake that goes on
when you put your PIN code in mobile
phones for better or worse are pretty
well encrypted these days specially
iPhones but then also we've got some
more you know non security related
things like Bitcoin and the other 4
million coins that are out there in the
world today and also electronic voting
systems as well I don't have anyone when
to talk on electronic votes in earlier
or voting is quite interesting ok so we
start off with random numbers so random
numbers are kind of important to
cryptography it's what we use for
generating a lot of encryption keys or
assaults on passwords so having the
ability to generate good random numbers
is quite important to us now
traditionally when you talk about random
numbers people think about a system dot
random and well so it's good for you
know generating not to read lottery
numbers or dice rolls or anything like
that it's not really robust enough to
use for cryptography because if you pass
the same seeds into system but random
you'll get the same set of numbers out
so
terminus stick which is not beautiful so
I said you can use something like RNG
crypto service provider which lives in
system dot security doc cryptography
along with everything else that we're
talking about today it's very easy to
use so if we look here we have a method
we pass in a length that length is going
to be the length of a byte array that we
want to initialize so if he's using a
256 bit AES key for example that'd be 32
we pass into them your instance the rng
crypto service provider initialize an
array to desired length call get bytes
and then that array is populated with
lots of random data which is fantastic
it's returned as a byte array so hashing
is a next set of primitives that we're
looking at and I guess he's probably the
one which most people are familiar with
and tends to get used the most and
hashing a good way of thinking of it is
it's kind of like an electronic
fingerprint for a piece of data so if
you have some data yeah a PDF document
or string credit card number whatever
parse it into a hashing function and you
get hashing code out the other end if
you modify that data just slightly and
rerun the hash code you get a completely
different hash code out the end of it so
there's four you know core properties
for hashing that we try to adopt so
first of all it should be easy to
compute pieces they to pass through a
function gets a result it's gonna be
easy it should be infeasible to generate
a specific hash so you shouldn't be able
to start with a hash code and think well
piece of data do I need to generate this
hash you shouldn't be able to you know
pre guess what that date is gonna be it
should be infeasible to modify a message
without changing the hash so what do you
discuss if you change just one bit in
your original date so you expect the
entire hash to change not just a little
bit of it and it should be infeasible to
find two identical hashes so if you have
two different pieces of data you run
them for a hash algorithm you shouldn't
get the same hash code out the back of
it that's called a hash collision and
somehow algorithms are susceptible to
hash collisions I think sha-1 has been
recently as well
another good way of sort of framing a
mental model around hash ins it's kind
of like one-way encryption in a way so
you have a piece of dates you generate
the hash code but you can't go back from
the hash code to the original piece of
data it's a one-way operation whereas
encryption typically it's a two-way
operation you know has some data
encrypted of a key decrypt up the same
key you get data back now md5 is quite
an old hashing algorithm it produces a
16 by a hash value invented by Ron
reversed of RSA Fame it was well it came
out in 1991 but it was discovered to
have a hash collision resistant
vulnerability in 1996 which means it's
not what you'd want to use in a
brand-new system you're still worth
talking about and knowing about it
because if you're like I was at a bank
integrating with some older systems that
sent you md5 hash codes back for some
data you still have to know how to
generate them in dotnet so for legacy
supports it's still relevant then you've
got the secure hash family so you've got
sha-1 and sha tsui which are available
in dotnet core so sha-1 gives you 160
bit hash function which is 20 bytes and
then you've got shots so which gives you
256 bits or 512 bits so 32 and 64 bytes
of a hash data there is a new one called
sha free which was designed well the
original shy algorithms were designed as
part of a competition which were run by
the NSA obviously out makes people a
little nervous so sha free was a
competition to come up with a new
algorithm that didn't have NSA
involvement that is now adopted as a
standard but Microsoft hasn't
implemented it yet there are open source
versions if he can get that what he it's
up to you if you trust those or not
hashing very easy to do in dotnet so if
we look at Shar 256 for example got a
sample method here you know we parse in
a byte array of our data that we want to
hash because typically everything works
with byte arrays in cryptography you
just call the static method create on
the char 256 objects and you call
compute hash parse your dates are in
then you get hash code
so very very powerful property that
hashing gives you it's actually very
easy to use which is fantastic that's
what we want so building on top of that
we have what's called authenticated
hashing and this is pretty much the same
as normal hashing you know have some
data run it through the function get a
hash code back but in this case you also
provide a key as well encryption key so
32 by key so what this means is if I
generate a hash code for a piece of data
and I send it to one of you if you want
to generate that exact same hash code
you have to be in possession of that key
if you have a different key then the
hash codes won't match so you can kind
of think of that key is a bit like a
really long password in a way so hash
measure authentication codes they verify
integrity and authentication
you can use H max based on md5 in the
char family of hashes in doc nets
strength is based on the key length so
obviously the longer the key the more
secure that's going to be and the most
common attack against it is a brute
force against that key that's where you
just keep on trying you know millions of
combinations until you get the right key
again face inputs use just a few lines
of code in dotnet core so you have a H
Mack char 256 objects pass the key into
the constructor then called compute hash
on your desired piece of data and you
get your hash code back out the other
end it's the same if you're doing a H
make char five twelve why H make char 2
so H make md5 it's the same interface so
little detour into passwords so
unfortunately passwords are here to stay
and I'll be trying to encourage our
users to use things like two-factor
authentication and better authentication
methods but a lot of users still prefer
passwords because it's easier for them
to remember so how we store those
passwords is very important but when you
get data breaches where you have you
know people's usernames and passwords
hashes in there typically you're gonna
get things like a brute-force attack
against our password which is where you
use a tool our hash Katz to repeatedly
you know just try it billions of
different combinations until they get
the same hash for a part
or you can do what's called a dictionary
or rainbow table attack which is a
massive precomputed dictionary of
passwords so they have to do is pass the
hash into this dictionary it will just
tell them what the past where it is and
these dictionaries have gigabytes in
size and you could just download them
freely off the internet using a taller
hash cap which uses whatever GPU is
installed on your system obviously means
it's very very fast a good demo I've
done for some of my more corporate
customers before is you use a tool like
this which is crack station nets you can
paste a sha-256 hash in there you just
type in the CAPTCHA code hit crack hash
and it tells you what the password is so
it's kind of a good little demo that you
can do to scare executives the next
better way of doing it and this is
probably still one of the more common
ways in which companies um store
passwords is you have a password and in
your upend what's called a salt onto the
end of it so salt is just a random piece
of data that you generate and a large
random number append those together
called the hashing function then you
store the hash and you store the salt so
the idea is you're supposed to make it
hardest do a brute-force attack although
if someone manages to steal all the
salts and can tie them up with the
passwords they're not seen that becomes
a moot point anyone use that technique
in their companies yeah quite still
quite common so really what we want to
try and do if you want to try and make
sure that trying to crack these is more
difficult and with Moore's law and
processor speeds and GPU speeds
increasing constantly you know they can
check what you know two three four or
five billion combinations per second on
a powerful GPU it's what we wants to do
is to artificially artificially wants it
deliberately slow down the hashing
process which is where we'll look at
something called a password-based key
derivation function which if you're not
familiar with it it sounds quite
frightening but it's actually quite
simple so a password-based key
derivation function or pbkdf2 as it's
commonly known is it's very similar to a
salted hash so you have your password
you pass in a salt and you pass in a
number of iterations what a number of
iterations is gonna do is it's gonna
Pete Earley hash the password before it
returns the hash to you so if you put a
number in there like you know 350 2427
it's gonna do you know over 300,000
repeated iterations point you see that
hash back so that means if anyone is
using hash cat to try and crack your
passwords instead of doing billions of
combinations per second you might be
able to reduce them down to a thousand
or 100 or depending depending on what
value you say it you might notice on
some websites when you put username and
password it feels like you're waiting
you know three to five seconds before
anything happens probably cuz I do one
of these behind the scenes or an
equivalent like bcrypt which is kind of
a conceptually similar process well you
need to store it somewhere in your
database because you need to present the
same salts when you anyhow your password
oh yeah so a pbkdf2 actually has a
proper standard its name is it's an RFC
two eight nine eight
so whoever implemented this in dotnet
decided to call it RFC two eight nine
eight derive bytes not really obvious
what it does unless you're intimately
familiar with RFC numbers I guess you
know it some people it makes complete
sense you know if you saw adding a
documentation you probably just skip
over it it doesn't make sense which is a
shame because it is incredibly easy to
use you just instantiate the class pass
in the data you want sir or costing the
password is a bytes are you passing your
salt give that a number of iterations
and then you call get bytes there isn't
you return 20 in this case is because
this implementation uses sha-1
internally which gives you 160 bit hash
which is 20 bytes so the number of
iterations you pass in obviously means
it's gonna take more time when I
calculated that table I is using a much
older laptop I tested it yesterday you
know on this this machine here if you
know several million as the iteration
count it still took this in a second so
you need to think about what's an X
double level of delay for your business
that's kind of a business decision we'll
see the higher that number the more
secure that passwords gonna be so I know
Troy's mentioned this in his talks but
it's this is a good example so has
anyone heard of Ashley Madison or the
Ashley Madison data breach so this
website can really be described as kind
of like a dating website I guess they
encourages people to have affairs it's
pretty shady what it does I don't
particularly know when they got hacked I
was like yes but there's an interesting
story behind it Sam this must have been
an inside job as well because as well as
all the passwords being installed and
all the usernames etc and all of the
source code was extracted as well which
you know makes you kind of feel like it
was an inside job so with their
passwords they used something called
bcrypt to hash their passwords it's
similar to what we've just looked at in
dot measures an alternative home
implementation so they using bcrypt
their passwords which is great it's
quite good password security but when
they look through the source code they
found that some enterprising software
developer tried to optimize the process
slightly so that you can log in faster
so after your first login you then store
an md5 hash over the password so you can
speed up the login process next time
brilliant
once they found that out there obviously
managed to go easily reverse engineer
all of the passwords because md5 hashes
are incredibly easy to crack these days
and if you're interested in that story
in further detail Ars Technica did a
fantastic news piece and kind of what
happened and what the ramifications were
another reason I like to include this in
talks obviously it's a horrible websites
and when when all the states ally so had
quite a big impact on people's lives so
obviously if you've been caught having
an affair and your usernames in there
that's quite embarrassing some people
you know it broke up families the most
severe case is a few people actually
committed suicide over it
so it just goes to show that the you
know what we do as software engineers
can actually have quite a big human
impact anyway on that low note let's
move on
so symmetric encryption supposed to be r
downer so symmetric encryption suppose
you know we start getting some of the
fun stuff this is where you encrypt
later with a key the cryptic the same
came to everyone knows that you know
we're at a security conference but the
problem with symmetric encryption is
sharing keys is hard it's very hard I
mean if I want to encrypt and data and
send it to one of you how do I get that
key to you I'm not going to stick it on
a text file on D Drive although I've
seen that happen I'm not gonna Tommy I'm
not going to email it to you maybe I
could physically meet you and hand you a
USB key that might be a good way of
doing it but gain the keys between
people is very very hard so that's one
of the downsides of symmetric encryption
again going back to our mental model
where we talked about caching so hashing
was a one-way operation encryption is
two-way so the way encryption algorithms
work is they take a load of date so they
split it down into blocks the blocks at
the end might be padded in some way if
they don't quite fit up the block and
then you have lots of different repeated
operations which happen on these blocks
where they get you know different
process is done to the many kicks all
together and eventually out the other
end you can get some encrypted data so
for computers this is very very fast
it's what computers are good at it's
just some good algorithmic support now
we have so in Prior to.net core we have
things like AES crypto service provider
there's crypto service provider and
Triple DES crypto service provider her
kind of free symmetric algorithms
available to us they all derive from a
symmetric algorithm based class which
means they will pretty much identical in
how you use them which is good des and
Triple DES again you're not gonna use
those in a brand new system but you know
if you are in a larger older company
chances are you might have to integrate
with some older legacy systems so I
worked for an online bank is one of the
first online banks in the UK about our
back-end banking platform was like a you
know UNIX based as/400 mainframe system
and all of our data is encrypted with
Triple DES and so often you had to deal
with some of that data
but Germany if you're going to use a
system these days you're gonna use AES
so AES is a nest standard from 2001
based on the Ryan dollar cipher by two
Belgian mathematicians Joan Damon and
Vincent Roman and the way this works is
to pass into the system you have your
plaintext that's a date you want to
encrypt you have different key strengths
so 128 192 or 256 bit keys Germany gonna
go for the higher key lengths 256 bits
and you also pass in something called an
initialization vector which is a 16
bytes random number which is used to
basically jumpstart the first block of
the encryption the initialization vector
you do need to store it with your
encrypted data because you have to pass
the same IV back.you mini decrypt your
data but it's not the secret keys not
classed as a secret there in dotnet
there's and don't they call there's two
versions of AES or the older version of
AES is AES managed or AES crypto service
provider the difference is a EES managed
is written in dotnet it's a native not
met implementation but it's not fit
certified whereas AES crypto service
providers its underlying windows
cryptography platform and it is Phipps
197 - 2 certified what that means is
it's been independently tested which
means it will be compatible with other
implementations also had the
certification so if you've got some data
that was encrypted
you know if Java Java implementation if
they're ones hip certified it means
you're gonna be able to download the
same information so generally you tend
to use this reasonably straightforward
to you so it uses streams these is a
memory stream in a crypto stream so we
passed in our data the key in the IV
instantiate the AES crypto service
provider initialize our streams pass the
data in got this thing here IES create
encryptor
which you have to call cool riots call
flush block turn it into an array return
it and that's your encrypted data the
encryption is identical the only
difference is it's sort of creating
crypt so we're passing in create decrypt
sir
so it's relatively straightforward and
this is what we've had available
twisting dotnet and dotnet core for a
long time
well not so much a long time snot net
core but traditional net this is kind of
what we've had to play with and in
dotnet core we get something called AES
GCM mode or Gallia's counter mode and
there's not another version called CCM
but GCM is the most useful version
service and it is good you know GCM mode
in AES has been around a while but it's
only just come to dock mats which is
good now traditionally when you use
normal AES like the one we just looked
at a traditional use case would be that
you encrypt some data and then you might
produce a hash Mac of that data
afterwards which you then store with the
date so so here's an encrypted date so
I've now got a you know an authenticated
hash of the data so we can tell if it's
been modified at a later date
what GCM mode does is it does that
caching process as part of the
encryption process so sort of during an
encrypt and then hash we're basically
getting the whole thing done in one go
and GCM mode has been designed to be
highly parallel and very very fast and
efficient there's even in turn
instructions and modern chips now
instead of passing in a 16 bytes
initialization vector they've now called
it a nonce number once and instead of
being 16 bytes it's 12 bytes for a GCM
mode also you're passing your key you
know 32 by 256 bit key and you can also
pass him what's called Associated data
sis he's effectively metadata that you
can pass in along with your data that
you want to encrypt so a good example of
that might be if you're encrypting
personal information for a customer so
name address phone number dates of birth
etc The Associated Day Tea Party might
be the database key ID but you know
which isn't necessarily relevant to that
record on its own but you must pass it
in as a bit of additional metadata
you don't have to pass it in you can
just pass null if you don't want to do
that what we also get out which I've
actually left the arrow off of the
diagram that's a bit silly there's
another thing we get out as well as a
sigh the ciphertext is called a tag now
that tag is effectively H Mac of the
encrypted data so to use it it's very
straightforward
so we have a method here which I've
written so we're passing our data to
encrypt it passing our key vertice bytes
passing the nonce 12 by trand imparting
are associated data if we want to
initialize an empty tag we create an
array for a ciphertext we instantiate
the AES GCM class passing the key into
the constructor then you just call
encrypt and then from that I'm returning
a tuple or topple or tuple depend on how
you want to pronounce it if the
ciphertext and the tag and when you come
to decrypt the data you pass in your
ciphertext okay that's what you want to
decrypt you pass in your key you pass in
the nonce you pass it the same tag that
was returned previously and you pass it
the same associated data if there was
any now what it will do is when you pass
that tag in it's going to check the
integrity of that data as its decrypting
it if there's an issue of it it's going
to abort from for an exception so
whereas before we said you do you know
an AES encryption then a hash Mac and
then what you might do is you might do a
hash map check and then a decription
this is doing it all as part of the same
process
okay so asymmetric encryption um you
know this is discussed and this morning
so everyone's been probably familiar
with it so it's based on the idea of
having a key pair of public key and a
private key these keys are based on
prime numbers so what it will mean is if
I want to send some data encrypted data
is one of you what I do is I request
your public key which you send me
because it's public anyone can know that
I encrypt the data with your public key
I send you that data and then you
decrypt it with your private key because
it's only known to you so RSA was
developed by RSA data security
incorporated by Rivest Shamir and
Adleman and it's based on the fact that
there's no way to fact a very large
prime numbers caveat until quantum
computers come along you know a minimum
recommended key length is 80 2048 bits
but whenever I've used it we've got a
straight to 4096 bits which is a nice
strong key at the moment so RSA is a
mathematical encryption scheme as
supposed to be now grief meekly yes is
he's incredibly fast and efficient but
sharing keys is hard asymmetric
encryption the key sharing problem is
better cos you've got this split key
concept but it's incredibly slow to
encrypt a to prevent and there's also a
limit as well in that you can only
encrypt data up to the size of the key
including your padding so you can't just
have a huge piece of data and then
encrypt it virus a because it won't work
so if I was to say top the whole idea
around prime numbers if I was to say to
you you know what is 23 times 17 what
I'm not gonna Kenny 1 do I just put the
answer on the screen but you know that's
quite an easy something to work out I
need he had a heart attack this morning
so I thought she's gonna ask me that
math question I managed to dodge it up
one she took the guy next to me so the
answer is 391 very easy to work out but
if I was to say to you and you know if
anyone can work it out please let me
know what are the two prime numbers that
make five thousand nine hundred and
sixty three that's quite hard to work
out anyone wanna have a quick
okay so 67 and 89 so if you equate this
back to you know a mental model around
public and private keys a public key is
the result of those primes a five
thousand nine hundred and sixty three in
the private key is those two factored
prime numbers now a real RSA key has
more components to it but that's kind of
like the fundamental principle but an
RSA keys may be a lot bigger than the
number five thousand nine hundred and
sixty-three it's gonna be from here
probably stretching into the center of
Oslo is a really really long number so
trying to break that number down to its
constituent prime numbers is incredibly
hard that's what computers struggle with
at the moment I'm saying at the moment
I'm being very cautious
so using RSA in dotnet is incredibly
simple which is great so your first free
one sir generates from new keys and I
didn't design these API some the API
designing this is a bit questionable so
I've got a method here called assign a
new key and you Stan shape RSA crypto
service provider tell it what strength
of key you wants then you call export
parameters by passing in false to get
your public key and you're passing true
to get your public key so that yeah that
puts the two keys in those public
property private properties at the top
they're encrypting data again only a few
lines of code so you instantiate RSA
crypto service provider you imports your
public key is always encrypted public
key we call encrypt given it our byte
array of our data and that's going to
return our encrypted data to us to
decrypt it gave me and Stan Show RSA
crypto service provider we import our
private key or the recipients private
key or they import their key I should
say you call decrypt then that gives you
your decrypted data back that's RSA
incredibly simple to use in Nets
the final primitive I want to look at
before we sort of look at how typically
some of these things are used together
is digital signatures so a digital
signature has free kind of properties or
free methods to it there's the key
generation you have a signing algorithm
for signing some data and you have
what's called a signature verifier now
the reason we sign data is because it's
a good way of proving that some data
originated from us often or from you so
if you think about what we said before I
say if I want to send some data to you I
request your public key I encrypts the
data then you decrypt it if your private
key the signing process is kind of
flipped it uses RSA in this case under
the covers or while making a lookout
being said to me as the originator I
sign the data with my private key only I
have that private key so when I send you
the data and you want to verify it came
from me you verify it with my public key
if the verification process comes back
and says true you know that data could
have only come from me or criminal that
stolen my private key now because it's
based on RSA as you said no there's
limits the amount of data that you can
process in one go so typically what you
do is you create a sha-256 hash or H Mac
of that data that you want to sign and
then you sign the hash which is a much
smaller piece of data
okay so again very easy to use so the
key generation process is you know
exactly the same slide as what we saw
before for RSA to perform a digital
signature or just assign it we have to
use this class here called RSA pkcs1
signature for matter which is a
brilliant name so we instantiate the RSA
crypto service provider we import our
private key because that's a person
doing the signing I'm gonna use my
private key instantiates RSA RSA pkcs1
signature format so we tell it what
hashing algorithm we're gonna use by
passing in a magic string that says char
256 and then we call create signature
passing in the hash of our data and that
will give us a byte array back that
contains our digital signature so we
send some data to a recipient so he send
them you know the hash of the data that
we wanted to sign we send them the
signature and they come along and they
request my public key or maybe they've
already got a copy of it they import the
public key they call RSA or they
instantiate RSA pkcs1 signature D
formatter
again today they're using char 256 and
then they call verify a signature
passing in a hash of the data and their
signature and it was turning for true or
false yes it verifies no it doesn't a
digital signature is that they yeah
they're very useful is anyone used
services like DocuSign to sign contracts
or some of the equivalents so taking
DocuSign is an example and if your
wanted to sign a contract to someone for
a piece of work or to buy a house they
upload the contract into DocuSign you
read it you tell it you want to sign it
and it puts a nice little pretty graphic
of a signature on there behind the
scenes it creates a digital signature
like what we've done here and that gets
stored in a database and the next person
comes along you know the originator of a
document they if you signed it they then
countersign it and that creates another
digital signature so what this also
means is that you know if it was say for
a piece of work and then you agreed that
they're gonna pay you ten thousand euros
of his piece of work
if you then come along and say no I want
fifteen thousand they gonna go well no
we've got mathematical proof
you signed this document with your
private yeah your private key and we
countersigned it so we have proof that
that document says ten thousand not
fifteen thousand that's kind of how
services are DocuSign and implement
digital signatures it's handy because
you can use digital signatures as proof
in court okay so we talked about the
four pillars earlier so confidentiality
will be looking to AES and RSA for that
integrity we looked at char 256 or vent
occasionally nuggets at hash mark char
a non repudiation we looked at digital
signatures so kind of some example
primitives in net that we can use to
satisfy each of those four pillars so I
want to look at now I only got twenty
minutes so look at now is how you know
some of these things might get used
together because you know it's like a
box of tools and you have towards me you
know combine them together to produce
other tools this will give you a kind of
a good idea of how things like
end-to-end messaging or maybe TLS things
like that work which is good so start
off with the first example so he talked
about how the fact that RSA has limits
on the amount of data that you can
encrypt in one go so that's a limitation
but we also mentioned the AES is
incredibly fast and efficient but key
sharing is hard so what we can do is you
can use two of those together to give us
a way to have fast encryption with good
key management so who works for as an
example so he generates an AES key which
is 32 bytes as we demonstrated earlier
we encrypt our data with a yes nice and
fast then we take our recipients public
key and we encrypt that key that we've
just generated and we send our AES
encrypted data and that encrypted AES
key over to our recipients first of all
they use their private key to decrypt
that accession key once they've done
that if then got the raw AES keys which
maybe should get that key to the other
person securely one set the cryptic that
key they can then go and decrypt the AES
state that we send them and meet the
message
yeah so if you think about something
like TLS as an example what happens when
you create a connection to a server
you've got your two parties they swap
their public keys
they generates a session key potentially
with a yes they use RSA to swap that key
between each other and then they've got
a channel or you can send encrypted data
backwards and forwards fundamentally you
know it's a similar principle so if it's
a think of that as deep as a packet of
data that we're gonna sense for someone
so we have our RSA encrypted session key
we've got our AES encrypted data and we
also had the AES initialization vector
so I should have mentioned that the
previous diagram let's walk it through
as an example so we've got Alice and Bob
and they can have a two-way conversation
with each other let's work it through so
Alice generates a key she generates an
initialization vector so the ivy is 16
bytes this AES keys photos two bytes Xin
crypts her message with AES then uses
Bob's public key to encrypt that AES key
sends it over to Bob where he can then
start the process of reading it so what
he does is he uses his private key to
recover or decrypt that AES key he then
uses that decrypted AES key and his
initialization vector which he can then
use with AES to decrypt the message so
the message was meet me at noon below
the clock tower where a red rose in your
button try make it a bit more James Bond
great so now Bob wants send a message
back to Alice to confirm his a meeting
with her so he generates a new session
key in this case he generates a new
initialization vector he equips his
reply using those pieces of data he then
uses Alice's public key to encrypt his
new AES key sends a message to Alice and
she can then start the process of
reading it so she uses her private key
to recover that key when she's got that
key she's ies to decrypt the message
which is I will meet you I'll be wearing
a blue hat and red boots
she's a height of fashion
yes so if when you send the message to
the recipient they have to have the same
IV so you send the IV to them because
they sent the new IV back so if you
think of it as a packet of information
it's been sent between the people and
raise the slider so that's what's being
sent the RSA encrypted session key the
initialization vector and the encrypted
data okay that's right now okay so the
next thing you might want to do so if
we're using you know the older version
of AES in dotnet you know the non GCM
version this is what we might want to do
next exactly the same process generate
the session cave generate an IV encrypt
them clip the data with AES encrypt the
session key with the public key now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna get our
cipher text we're gonna get the IFV
we're gonna combine them together and
then we're gonna create a hash mac using
the high es key was the key and then
we're gonna send that hash back along
with the rest of the data that we sent
across the reason for that is on the
other side Bob has got to recover the
AES key once he's recovered that key or
decrypted the key he then has the
ability to calculate the same hash Mac
that was sense he can compare them if
they're the same he knows no one's
tampered with the data and then he can
go and decrypt the data this gives him
the concept of integrity and
authentication keys in a hash Mac so not
only if we solved the problem of how do
we get a symmetric key between two
parties we've also guaranteed that's you
know you have to decrypt that key first
to calculate the hash so you obviously
the recipient needs their private key or
the correct private key and we can also
tell whether that message has been
tampered with or corrupted in transit so
if we look at the packet of data that
we'd send so obviously we're sending the
RSA encrypted session key initialization
vector
the AES encrypted data and also our hash
of the encrypted data in the IV the
reason we include the IV in the hash
mark is because if someone messes around
with the IV but wants better tell if
it's changed so by including it in the
hash Mac we can tell that so if he was
using GCM mode it's slightly different
because in Gallia's counter mode in AES
we don't need to calculate that hash
mark afterwards it happens internally
inside the algorithm for us which is
good so actually our diagram of who's
using GCM may look very much like the
first diagram no we encrypt some data
with an IAS key we encrypt the AES key
we send it to the recipient
but because IES uses a nonce instead of
an IV we store that nonce in the packets
and because GCM mode returns us a tag
which is effectively a Hodge back we
also store that tag and we send it to
the recipient so the process is you know
it's a little bit more simple less code
to write which is nice okay so we've
managed to swap our keys we've managed
to add integrity and authentication into
the process so now let's add the final
pillar and see what that looks like and
we'll do orphaned within non-repudiation
okay so as an example again exactly the
same generate an Aes key in an IV
encrypt our date so if those pieces of
information use the recipients public
key to encrypt our AES key you know
we've created we need to create a hash
Mac of the ciphertext a nonce and the
tag and I'll come on to why in a moment
but we need to even if we using GCM mode
we still have to create a hash back in
this case I mean then use that hash Mac
that we pass in to our digital signature
algorithm to create a digital signature
now you might be thinking if the tag is
a H Mac why do we need to generate
another H Mac that's because that tag is
a different format than don't know what
for what the digital sync trial with him
is expecting so if you pass that tag
into it and tell it that you're doing a
sha-256 hash it's right know what to do
so it's a different format
so that means in this case we have to do
a scythe we have to do a hash mark
anyway so that means our packet
information looks like this throughout
the session key initialization vector or
nonce there cryptic data we have our
hash mark and we have the digital
signature so the benefit that this gives
us them so again we've got the ability
to securely transfer a symmetric key
between two parties so we've solved that
problem obviously we get confidentiality
to encrypt in our data and we've got
with the key safety swapped between
people
we've got integrity and authentication
because we've got this hash Mac or tag
from the encrypted data that's good what
a moment even gives you is proof that it
was you that said that piece of data
because you create a digital signature
of your private key when they come to
when Bob comes to verify the signature
on his end he has to use the sender's
public key if it returns true when he
verifies you know that you knows it was
Alice it sent that message it's a very
sense take you see it means you can
verify the authenticity of that message
you know the original original the
originator which is quite cool so near
here in the press you know you hear
people talking about you know how evil
end-to-end communications are
effectively what's going on behind the
scenes is something very similar to this
so if you look at if you download the
spec for the signal protocol obviously
SiC the signal protocol is more complex
in this but fundamentally is doing
something very similar to this it's
using an asymmetric system for
negotiating keys that could be RSA it
could be elliptic curve or
diffie-hellman or n if you have a key
exchange protocols but fundamentally
it's using this principle of split key
you know the actual encryption if your
day to itself is going to be done using
a symmetric algorithm so in our case it
was a EES but it could be things like
Blowfish
or to fish or any of the other symmetric
algorithms so hopefully what this gives
you is it gives you a bit familiarity
and kind of house on these systems work
I hope
yeah okay so we covered quite a lot
quite quickly there so the workshop I've
done over the last two days we kind of
went through this a lot slow with lots
of code examples pros officer have tried
to jab this into an hour but we've
covered random numbers so we use those
for generating our encryption keys and
our IVs salts for passwords we've looked
at hashing and H max so they give us our
integrity and authentication enables us
to tell whether something's been
tampered with
if you've ever downloaded software from
some size before they sometimes give you
a little bit of text underneath which
says the md5 or the sha-256 hash for
that piece of software so that you can
check what you downloaded matches what
was on the server we look to secure
password storage look you know various
different methods of doing that plain
hashing of passwords whilst it used to
be sufficient is now easily a problem it
can be easily attacked secure well
salted hashes of passwords is a much
better solution but with Moore's law the
advent of GPU technologies increasing
kind of tenfold every year you can't
guarantee how long those passwords going
to be secure so we looked at a method
for artificial tone artificially we
looked at a method for deliberately
slowing down the hashing process so that
even if you're using a powerful GPU it
limits the amount of passwords you can
try and crack in one go which is very
useful recovered symmetric encryption in
our case you know we look to a es where
dotnet core was recently given this AES
GCM mode which is brilliant you know
lots of other systems have had it for a
long time you just take a Microsoft
awhile to catch up they've got their RSA
we looked at as an example of asymmetric
cryptography you know mathematical
process for generating prime number
based keys it's a very good transport
for swapping keys between two people or
two symmetric keys between two people
and then we looked at digital signatures
which gives us non-repudiation so being
able to prove that it was you that sent
a message for a piece of data which is a
very valuable thing to be able to do to
try and get trust
and we then looked at how to you know
combine some of these together just to
give some kind of you know examples of
how are things like TLS or enter end
chat systems work so when people are
talking about end-to-end encryption in
the press about how evil it is and
governments want to get rid of it it's
this so that it's this sort of thing
that they're trying to stop ok so what
next
some pretty good books here that
recommend if you're interested in going
a bit deeper on the subjects the code
book by Simon Singh is kind of like a
history book reads a bit like a novel
it's really really good starts on at the
ancient times of when and they used to
get soldiers shave their heads off write
messages on their heads wait for their
hair to grow back and then send them
send them on their way
brilliant genius and it goes right away
through up to kind of you know
reasonably modern digital cryptography
standards so it's just a really fun book
to read everyday cryptography by Keith
Martin he's a much more mathematically
dense book it talks about how a lot of
the algorithms work internally so if
you're genuinely interested in that sort
of thing that's a good book but then it
talks about how they used in practical
uses so things like how a cash machine
on ATM the go shades between the bank
how TLS works how encrypted streams on
netflix things like that work the final
book applied cryptography is the book
that they tried to ban in the 90s it
literally was banned at one point it's
it doesn't cover a yes because it came
out before IES was around but if you're
one of really really deep from a
practical guide on how a lot the
algorithms work that's the book for you
I've tried to read it and gave up his it
beat me it was too mathematical hey if
you're on Pluralsight I've got a few
courses here that you might find
interesting so practical cryptography
Nets kind of talks about what we've done
today but in more detail I'm looking to
update the course soon so all of the
source code that come to that book he's
kind of dotnet framework based but
pretty much everything in there will run
on donate colleges to project falls
through different formats I'm hope
you're gonna try and get that course
updated this year
the one behind play-by-play enterprise
data encryption with as you revealed is
just me talking about a Shiki vault and
how that works it's a good way of
protecting encryption keys online in
Azure and if you're interested in kind
of how hashing can be useful as a tool
in cryptography then I've got a course
called blockchain principles and
practices where we talk about the theory
of block chains kind of how they are how
they work what they could be useful for
where they're not useful and throughout
the course we actually build up an
implementation from scratch of a kind of
a working blockchain you kind of just
you know teaches you the principles
which you might find fun so with that
thank you very much we've got one more
talk left so try and stay awake for so
good luck